une carcasse de métal broyer voilà ce
qu'il reste d'un hélicoptère militaire
ukrainien a battu ce jeudi par l'armée
russe près de marioupol à son bord se
trouvaient dix sept personnes seules
deux ont survécu
l'offensive russe se concentrent
désormais en grande partie sur l'est du
pays le président ukrainien il redoute
une intensification des frappes sur les
populations civiles
dans le donbass à marioupol et en
direction de karkhiv les troupes russes
accule leur potentiel offensif de
puissante offensive
nous nous défendrons
nous ferons tout pour arrêter les
occupants et nettoyer notre terre de
leurs chimères malfaisante cerise est
absurde
parmi les zones visées le bassin minier
du don de basses et les villes qui
l'entourent comme idiome où les combats
sont particulièrement violent dans les
régions de donetsk et de loin les
troupes du craignent and his tenir leurs
positions face aux russes et aux
combattants séparatistes
ils ne veulent plus se battre parce
qu'ils ont subi beaucoup de pères
ils n'ont plus la force d'avancer et de
combattre ils sont beaucoup moins
nombreux
l'état-major russe donne de son côté une
toute autre version du conflit moscou
met l'accent sur des dizaines de
véhicules militaires détruits et évoque
d'importantes percées dans l'est du pays
le recentrage de l'armée russe sur la
région fait craindre aux ukrainiens
l'imminence d'offensive bien plus
puissante que les précédentes